we went to one protest out in bellevue
like the east like the east side of
seattle and [ __ ] and it was like a
perfectly peaceful approach like no one
was doing right nothing i was up front
bro i was like very front yeah i was up
in the
like and then
out of nowhere someone throws something
at a cop and then [ __ ] just goes
completely left like tear gas like the
little grenades that they brought yellow
grenades that go off so we're running
down the street like we're like me and
my manager shelton are like huffing this
gas like trying not to puke my homies
like pouring water and milk in people's
eyes and [ __ ] like and and it was crazy
to like watch like the news report on it
when i was right there and act like it
was like a violent protest violent
protest bro it was like and it wasn't
like someone threw a it was like a can
or something got thrown into a crowd of
cops and then it just went left and then
i'm watching people report on it and
they're just like all these violent
protests are like are they walking up to
kids who are looting like trying to get
in their faces and [ __ ] i'm like y'all
aren't reporting the story bro you're
just trying to get a sensationalized
version it's about ratings bro bro it's
[ __ ] it's and i i've always known
this about ratings i've always known
it's like they were going to show you
this [ __ ] which really this is going on
but like
going there in first person and seeing
like watching the protesters get like
stories spun on them was so ugly bro so
ugly so you feel me yeah she got hectic
in seattle but at the same time they
like sensationalized it and made people
look crazy when they were really just
making their voice heard